[Music]
hello and welcome to drive at the DW car
show coming up a muscular station wagon
for country roads outies rs6 Avant
performance a green convertible smart
fortwo electric drive Cabrio and the
honda civic type-r
then my on our car tester Michelle
Assenmacher says that the new Honda
Civic type-r comes with a more
cutting-edge design and an evil looking
front end she says she's going to have a
lot of fun with the car today but not
with this generation or that one but
with this one honda introduced that
tenth generation of the Civic at the
start of this year and the type r has
also been completely revised it looks
like a spaceship from a science fiction
film with its spoilers and sill boards
it puts many top-of-the-line sports cars
to shame but these details aren't just
for show
every thin and winged serves a purpose
together they help maximise forward
thrust at high speeds and make the Civic
a car for the race track at 200
kilometers an hour the chassis has to
withstand 30 kilos of air pressure with
a Type R form follows function i
catching external modifications help
cool the motor and the transmission the
new model sits 25 millimeters lower to
better hug the road
at the back it's giant wing and rear
diffuser optimized downforce
[Music]
our show says she still needs to do
something before she hits the track she
gets some quick instructions for the
test track and Dawn's a safety helmet
[Music]
[Applause]
the type-r uses a lot of the technology
that honda has developed for
professional car racing this compact
speedster has special air vents to
conduct heat a cooling channel reduces
the temperature of the Pistons a
lightweight crankshaft
and a flywheel increase responsiveness
and efficiency
Michelle says this is the first time
she's driven on a full-fledged racetrack
to be honest she says she was a bit
afraid at first but the car helped her
settle down it's really a lot of fun
under the hood there's a 2 liter VTEC
turbo engine with direct fuel injection
it has 235 kilowatts of power and goes
from 0 to 100 kilometers an hour and 5.7
seconds its top speed is 272 Michele
says the acceleration is amazing
although she's a novice on the test
track the car makes her feel assured so
she's confident enough to put the hammer
down in defiance again the new Type R
has three driving modes in addition to
comfort and sport there is our plus in
that mode the handling and throttle are
more direct the gears are more powerful
and the car is more agile for everyday
driving the comfort mode is better the
Honda Civic Type R is built to appeal
not just to amateur car racers but the
families as well Michelle says that the
car takes a bit of getting used to in
this respect but the vehicle offers the
driver lots of support it holds curves
and she can hit the gas whenever she
wants and the car doesn't let her down
Lucinda on the gas game on the
Evangelist and furnishing station the
interior has been completely redone and
there are marked improvements in quality
comfort and workmanship when you get
into the car you spot the red and black
sporty seats right away Honda has
lowered those seats by 5 centimeters
speed is displayed digitally in the
center of the tachometer the cockpit is
well designed on the drivers right-hand
side there's the gearshift for the
manual 6-speed transmission the
seven-inch touchscreen in the center
console has replaced a whole bunch of
buttons
[Applause]
Honda is proud of setting a record on
the Nurburgring demanding Nordschleife
of course for the lap time of seven
minutes and forty three point eight
seconds the type R is the fastest
front-wheel drive car ever as a show
says her test lap was really fun she's
still full of adrenaline and her hands
and knees are shaking but she says that
the Honda Civic Type R was a pleasant
surprise
and she had a really great day with it
even resolve our car test three Manuel
Schaefer says smarts new IDI or electric
drive convertible aims to be as clean as
the water from this spring the current
generation fortwo Cabrio has been on the
market since 2016 the new generation
smart electric drive came out just a few
months ago now Smart has combined the
two the Cabrio comes with the same 60
kilowatt electric motor that powers the
regular four to IDI to improve its range
top speed is electronically limited to
130 kilometers per hour
[Music]
a man was driving a convertible is great
though waiting at traffic lights in the
city and breathing in the exhaust from
the other cars isn't so nice so it's
good that due to its 150 kilometer plus
range you can also drive this kibriya
out into the countryside being
surrounded by green makes for a truly
green driving experience
the battery pack located in the
underbody has a capacity of seventeen
point six kilowatt hours a 22 kilowatt
onboard charger with fast charge
functionality is due out in Europe next
spring it should allow the battery to
charge to 80 percent in less than 45
minutes smarts project of Illinois
coordinator calls the Cabrillo a dream
car and the perfect city car it fits in
every parking space and as a tiny
turning radius like the regular smarts
with internal combustion engines but
with the electric drive there's the
added advantage that when driving around
with the top down we get to hear what's
going on around us we hear the birds
pedestrians other cars that's a unique
feeling that only an electric
convertible can deliver
I mean Escovedo meeting Connor on the
outside the electric drive Cabrillo
looks much the same as Smart's fuel
powered models potential buyers can find
out which version they're looking at by
reading the name on the emblems the
optional Braavos design package gives
the convertible a sporty look
the IDI logo which looks like a plug in
an electric socket figures prominently
at the side the soft top can be opened
up electronically but the roof bars have
to be removed by hand and then stored in
their designated place in the trunk that
reduces cargo space from 340 to 260
liters the Braavos tailor-made exterior
style package includes accents supplied
by the high performance tuning company
as well as LED tail lights the interior
is simple and uncluttered colorful
accents which match the paint job at a
bit of Pettit the display in the
speedometer shows the remaining range in
current speed a free-standing dial
provides data on the charging status and
the battery pack
like all the other four to models the
electric drive convertible has a tiny
turning radius of less than seven meters
together whether it's green Creed this
makes it an ideal city car smart is now
taking orders for the new fortwo Cabrio
electric drive prices started just over
25 thousand euros in Germany here
financial incentives are being offered
to get more electric cars on the road so
the real cost is less than 21 thousand
euros Kumanovo says for him Smart's
electric drive Cabrio has it all it
combines all the strengths of its fellow
smarts the compact external dimensions
the convertible experience and on top of
that its emissions free you could say
it's three cars in one
five becomes six this autumn BMW will
unveil the 6 Series Gran Turismo the
successor to the 5 Series GT the 6
Series GT looks more like a coupe a than
a sedan several engine options will be
available including the four-cylinder
gas-powered 630i
that generates 190 kilowatts and 400
Newton meters of torque it's been
carried over from the five series
six-cylinder diesel and gas powered
engines will also be on offer the latest
addition to the successful Skoda Octavia
line is the Rs 245 it's the fastest
Octavia ever with a 180 kilowatt engine
that's 11 kilowatts more than the RS 232
245 can jump from 0 to 100 km/h in 6.6
seconds and features a sport chassis
that's 15 millimeters lower than its
previous models German prices for the
sedan start at about 34 thousand euros
and 35 thousand for the station wagon
our s about e these two letters stand
for high-performance cars but they can
top them too we're testing out the Audi
rs6 Avant performance
it's got thirty-three kilowatts more
power than the standard rs6 Avant car
tester and elite Zimmerman says that the
best thing about the rs6 performance is
definitely the motor a four liter v8
with two turbochargers that puts out 445
kilowatts and an amazing 750 Newton
meters of torque that makes the rs6
performance one of the fastest station
wagons in the world the car goes from 0
to 100 kilometers an hour and just 3.7
seconds that's 0.2 seconds faster than
the basic rs6 model some people might
not like the rs6 Avant performances fuel
consumption and co2 emissions but this
vehicle is not designed to protect the
environment
these are mojo Andre says that the motor
grabs your attention with its beautiful
sound especially in leave dynamic mode
dynamic models
even when standing still this model rs6
projects Authority the chassis is about
six centimetres wider than the standard
a6
the tires are 275 millimeters wide on 20
inch rims extra length at the front and
especially the back are typical of this
series
[Music]
the powerful motor which is mounted in
front of the front axle is connected to
a classic Quattro Drive this layout
means that the car as a whole is front
weighted which affects its handling
[Music]
Hondo he says that although the rs6
sDrive is weighted more to the back
which means more torque is distributed
there this car is better suited to long
extrude stretches of Autobahn and long
curves than to tight curves which it
takes primarily with its front wheels
still you definitely feel safe an rs6
rapidly approaching in your rear-view
mirror is an imposing sight and there's
a dynamic plus option which costs an
additional 14 thousand euros and takes
the cars top speed at 305 kilometers an
hour
[Music]
the interior harkens back to the roots
of the Audi a6
but lots of carbon fiber trim RS logos
and the flat-bottom steering wheel still
give it a sporty feel the start button
is fiery red the honeycomb leather seats
are standard
[Music]
MIT family Andre says that the rs6
performance is not a sensible car but
people who can afford it will find that
this car will perform well in almost any
situation and besides not being sensible
can be a lot of fun like on the rs6 is a
station wagon of extremes
extremely fast extremely powerful
extremely exclusive and extremely
expensive
[Music]
what was stuffy a big country car
Chester honey let's Texas Volvo is known
for building robust cars like the second
generation of the xc90 it's in the top
class of SUVs the first generation Volvo
xc90 first hit the market in 2002
Volvo's stuck with a design for 13 years
that didn't go down well with some
dealers who prefer to see models change
every six or seven years so Volvo came
out with the second generation as
competition for the BMW x5 and Audi q7
honey points out that this xc90 is
powered by a four-cylinder engine with a
capacity of 2 liters various performance
and fuel options are available there's
even a plug-in hybrid but he thinks a
car this big should really have a v6
engine the family studies a POSIX clan
chorus the ultimate role of wood but
does the smaller engine mean that the
xc90 somehow has less to offer we're
going to test the d5 AWD model which
features four-wheel drive
[Music]
the Volvo our design gives this car a
performance inspired look and feel with
the enhanced Polestar version of the
engine the xc90 can jump from 0 to 100
km/h in 7.7 seconds and hit a top speed
of 220 kilometers an hour
rami says that this xc90 has been
outfitted with pole star performance
optimizing software which boosts engine
power by a whopping 4 kilowatts it costs
an extra 1200 euros but it's good value
for money the software not only boost
power but also torque to 500 Newton
meters instead of 480 you can really
feel the difference 1500 rpms can sure
get this 2 ton vehicle moving months
enough on our test car was painted
Sweden blue other options besides color
include 22 inch rims this version of the
xc90
is 15 centimeters longer than the
previous version and 2 centimetres wider
Ronnie says the car's interior is really
comfortable everything is where it's
supposed to be nice and tidy the
controls are all here on the big
touchscreen he thinks it all looks great
but it's a little awkward at first until
you figure out where everything is there
are more apps here than Ronnie has on
his phone and if you don't find the
heater app quickly you'll either freeze
or roast it maybe quibbling but he'd
still rather have a few proper push
buttons okay it's making a whole new
board as much as Michaan's refurbished
Ronnie really likes the Bowers & Wilkins
sound system whether it's 1,400 watts
and 20 speakers keynotes all interstate
the interior is quite posh there's
carbon fiber trim stainless steel and
leather everywhere you look
a 24 centimeter touchpad allows you to
control just about everything except the
basics there's lots of room in here too
even with five passengers and there's an
add-on option for a third row of seats
[Music]
mommy says that this model with the d5
diesel engine the our design features
Pulstar optimization and a few other
extras will cost around ninety thousand
euros this car has a lot to offer a
powerful engine a streamlined chassis
and a world-class sound system and the
seats are really comfortable
Futaba vino Ronnie says the Volvo xc90
is a first-class car and he can't wait
to see what Volvo comes up with next
[Music]
our classic car expert Christophe Bauer
is tooling around the northern Italian
province of Trentino in a Porsche on the
virtually empty roads of the plateau of
lava ani he finds it hard not to fall in
love with a 911 Targa deposit line
christophe says the Porsche 911 is the
sports car park Salons now as ever
its shape is immediately recognizable
here targis stands for the removable
roof which normally sits between the
windshield and the roll bar the Targa's
roll bar was the brainchild of company
chairman ferry Porsche and his son
Ferdinand Alexander Porsche who designed
the 911 the roll bar was made to protect
the convertibles inhabitants in case the
car flipped over
but its appearance drew mixed reactions
some even joke the targets brush tanner
hasta Steel rhobar reminded them of pots
and pans and had them reaching for their
dishcloths
still over a quarter of the 911s
produced at the time were targets
[Applause]
unfocus that christophe says that at
first the targa was a quick fix the US
was Porsches biggest market then and
still is today but in the 1960s an
ambitious lawyer named Ralph Nader
launched his unsafe at any speed crusade
to get dangerous cars off the roads
especially convertibles so Porsche
quickly developed a safe convertible
with a roll bar and the Targa was born
Christoph feels the name was well chosen
it harks back to the Targa Florio
endurance races held on Sicily and Targa
is an old word for shield clever huh the
Targa has been rolling off assembly line
since 1965 unlike its predecessor the
356 which had always been available as a
convertible the 911 only came as a coupe
a when the model was first introduced in
1963 knowin that knowing on things tough
tells us Porsche started fitting the
target with panoramic glass rear windows
in 1969 before that there was a plastic
one that zipped open the problem was you
often couldn't shut it again as the
plastic shrunk at low temperatures he
says this 1972 model has a different
weak spot to achieve better weight
distribution the oil tank was mounted
just ahead of the rear axle and filled
here you can guess what happened some
owners or gas station attendants filled
it with gas causing major engine damage
just a year later the oil tank lid was
history
it's harmonious shape has made the
portion 9/11 one of the world's most
beautiful and timeless sports cars the
target roll bar and the wraparound rear
window continue the flowing lines seen
at the front with its centrally placed
tachometer wings that are visible from
the driver's seat and ignition to the
left of the steering wheel the targa
boasts all the classic features of a 911
not to mention its rear engine a Porsche
trademark
[Applause]
this 911 T was the weakest variant of
the 6-cylinder 2.4 liter engine which
was fitted into the models starting in
1972
Christophe says these days 130
horsepower sounds more suitable for a
family car than a racy sports car but
not here as this is a porsche after all
the engine revs willingly and
accelerates quickly going from zero to
100 kilometres an hour in just 10
seconds and it can hit 200 km/h so you
can still drive it with confidence today
even the highway police appreciated the
cars combination of fresh air and
driving performance the hundred
thousandth Porsche ever made was a 912
Targa
equipped with a blue light for the
German police
[Music]
as a Cristo says fans swear the 911s
handling is second to none the rear
engine delivers endless amounts of
traction making frills like power
steering and ESP superfluous he calls it
the perfect recipe for endless driving
pleasure but compared to modern 911s
cornering stability is limited so when
you enter a curve quickly and suddenly
take your foot off the gas the rear end
can slide out then you must quickly
counter steer to get back on track
what's the biggie but such driving
challenges and the inimitable throaty
sound of the air-cooled boxer engine are
the ingredients that have made the
classic 911 such a success story
[Music]
then whenever Christoph says the 911 is
the most successful supercar of all time
like no other it balances sportiness
with everyday practicality and with the
911 target Porsche added a trend-setting
security concept
he says the cars the perfect synthesis
of hedonism and rationality of open-air
feeling and safety and that makes the
911 Targa a true milestone and
automotive history in 1982 another
Porsche started to give the Targa a run
for its money the 911 convertible after
a 16-year break the sports car maker
returned to making open top vehicles
without roll bars still the Targa
remains and Porsches lineup to this day
and next time on drive it a great city
runabout with new details the Skoda
Citigo and putting the Jaguar F peace
through its paces
[Music]
[Music]